hi thanks for joining us for another
live Q&A this time we're talking about
the us-china trade war I'm Sarah I'm a
video journalist here at the Economist
and I'm here in London with Henry Kerr
our economics editor Sameach Keynes our
trade and globalization editor also
joins us from DC hi Henry - mayor great
to have both here last week we published
a film about why the trade war is not
going to end anytime soon if you haven't
watched it already you can find it by
clicking on the I in the top right hand
corner of the screen or below in the
description thank you to those of you
who sent in questions already we'll be
going through some of those with Henry
and Tamir now you can still send in
questions live just in the chat box to
the right and we'll be keeping an eye on
those as we go Sameach you're the
journalists here who's been closest to
this story have there been any
particular challenges covering this for
the last year and a half or so yeah I
think the main one is that it has been
going on for a really really long time
and despite the large number of angry
tweets in terms of progress in terms of
achieving much there hasn't really been
much so for most of that time the story
has basically been the same which is
there are tariffs the Trump
administration wants really big changes
from the Chinese but they're just
there's a huge amount of uncertainty
about what is going to happen next and
what the Chinese are going to do that
kind of uncertainty makes for fairly you
know difficult sometimes unsatisfying
story writing because it's difficult to
say something very completely about
what's going to happen next week but
hopefully I've been able to live up for
that challenge live up to that challenge
the other the other thing I would say is
that it seems that the White House has a
weekly meeting on Thursdays we of course
go to print on our first thing on
Thursday morning and so the timing
hasn't been ideal for me personally
there have been a few ends and weeks
they've been slightly more stressful
than I wanted them to be I can see that
presents a challenge and Henry where
does the us-china trade war set
in the context of your reporting on the
world economy how big a deal is this in
the grand scheme of things well it's
been a very big story this year has been
the driving story I would say behind the
global economic narrative as it were
that in combination with the Federal
Reserve's monetary policy it's probably
between the two of those and what we've
seen throughout the year is the
sentiment about the trade or about
what's going on between the US and China
has been driving stock markets he's been
driving currencies it's been driving
sentiment about where growth is going to
go and also global going to pencil on
the sphere and so there's been a bit of
a debate running about the extent to
which that's trade driven and it isn't a
lot of people thing that it is trade and
business is a very uncertain they don't
want to invest because of that and a few
other things to go on as well their exit
of course but it's a very very big deal
very important story okay thank you and
before we get onto your questions a
quick update on the latest movements
would be really helpful
so Sameach it seems like the phase 1
deal that has been on the cards for
weeks now might be wavering and this
talk about being delayed until next year
is that a surprise or do you think it's
likely to be kicked even further down
the road yeah so at the last kind of big
formal announcement that had anything to
do with this the the president announced
that there would be a deal papered
within the next five to six weeks and
and actually when he announced it it
sort of sounded like he thought they've
got a deal and it was just a matter of
writing down the details crossing some
some some T's and dotting some eyes now
obviously I was very skeptical that they
were as close to an agreement as the
president was saying the devil is all in
the detail of these deals without a text
without something on paper concrete both
sides can kid themselves that they're
quite close to an agreement and then
when they see that text written down
they discover oh actually no we're not
willing to live up to those obligations
so I was always skeptical for the amount
of optimism the plan was to meet for the
press of trumpet and finish she campaign
to meet and sign this deal and that
meeting was going to be the forcing
event
right they were going to be together
they really wanted to sign this deal and
that occasion was going to essentially
force negotiators to come together and
resolve the the final differences and
then the you know the two had to stick
would would make that final call well
this Lee there was a big setback to that
plan because that meeting got cancelled
so now they face the situation where
actually there's a kind of open ending
its deadline and it's it's much more
difficult to get the political will to
get over that final head sort of hurdle
when you don't have that forcing event
so I was skeptical I without without
that event to force their action I was
skeptical that they were going to be
able to reach a deal very soon
that's reporting that says now it could
be next year I and so you know the
question is basically just the Trump
administration try to reimpose some
deadlines we have this deadline of
tariffs coming on on December 15th does
the Trump administration say well unless
we get a deal by then I'm going to you
know we're going to raise tariffs on a
huge number of products could that be
the thing that forces the deal or could
it just be the thing that essentially
means that the talks break down
completely and it and it kind of becomes
much more acrimonious great thanks man
and we'll come back to what might happen
next a bit later on but we want to start
with your questions about how this all
started and what exactly has been
happening so from initial saying which
of the two countries should be blamed
for the initiation of this trade war and
Henry trying to take this one that's a
hard and controversial question I would
say there's a short-term and a long-term
element to that in the short term it's
very clear that the election of
President Donald Trump was a crucial
event in kicking off the trade war you
took a stance on you know not really
been seen in from the White House before
when he was elected that said a lot of
the complaints that America has about
China on which the Trump administration
is acting
I have him running they've been to do
with intellectual property theft
for instance they vintage about state
subsidies of industry in China and these
are complaints that pre-existed that
existed before the top administration
and will outlast them it is noticeable
now that in Washington DC there's more
bipartisan consensus on China a lot of
people there are a lot of China Hawks
about there in the ascendancy but in in
terms of the causation it just goes to
show that those issues were sort of
probably even without the Trump
administration would have would have
come to a head sooner or later given the
geopolitical forces involved so I'd say
this is that it sort of depends which
which timescale you look at yep thank
you it's really interesting and and some
of you had questions about a data set
that we use in our film about the trade
war and it should be coming up in your
screen now it's a graph that shows how
China and America's tariff rates have
changed since the start of the trade war
you can find the source links in the
description below but people in our
community tab were surprised to see that
China's tariffs were higher than
America's when the trade war started
Sameach could you explain why that's the
case yeah so essentially when China
entered the World Trade Organization it
had a negotiation its first big
negotiation was was with the u.s. now
within the World Trade Organization
there tends to be a difference between
the tariffs obligations that richer and
poorer countries have so richer
countries tend to have lower tariffs
essentially they've been through all
these rounds of negotiations to lower
their tariffs kind of in recognition
that often these tariffs aren't very
good for them but developing countries
essentially don't have as many
responsibilities within that rating
system they tend not to have negotiated
their tariffs down so much so China is
sort of you know on average not a rich
country it's obviously very large itself
declares as a developing country within
the World Trade Organization as a result
of the negotiation with the u.s. it
ended up with higher tariffs on average
with the u.s. that said China actually
has much lower average tariffs than
other comparable developing countries
right so the u.s. actually did negotiate
pretty hard with China when China
entered so that China actually had more
responsibilities when it entered the
trading system than its developing peers
so you know one needs to be careful in
terms of which takeaways you draw away
you draw from from that chart showing
that China's tariffs are on average
higher than America's great thank you
and we've actually just had a live
question in so you decide who's going to
take this will the trade will bring
about the increase in currency rate of
RMB so I could take that
so typically what's happened throughout
the trade war every time things have
gone badly or the trade was escalated
that has led to the decline of China's
currency the renminbi against the US
dollar the numerous reasons for that is
partly because the dollar is a safe
haven asset so whenever things have
seemed to go wrong people rush into the
into the into dollar assets it's also
because in theory when you put tariffs
on someone else's goods in theory that
should push up your currency for various
reasons now of course China and the US
Open in currency are putting tariffs on
each other so you might think that's
offsetting but America imports a lot
more from China and China imports from
America so ultimately a trade breaks
down that that force probably goes in
one direction too so and there was
actually a pretty seismic event earlier
this year when China who which manages
its currency that's the other difference
of course between the between the
America and China China manages its
currency and it's allowed the renminbi
to weaken through the symbolic threshold
of over seven to the dollar and that was
seen as a very important event and when
that happened
stock markets moved a lot as well I
think if you would see the resolution of
the trade war you probably see some
movement in the other direction I think
the dollar would weaken and China's
currency
I would probably strengthen some wards
if it worsens a lot
I think you're going to continue to see
the dollar strength we've seen great and
there's a another live question that
kind of follows on from that from
Ricardo Hamilton and is the u.s. dollars
global dominance at risk that's a really
good question one of the curious things
about the current decade is that China's
economic rise has become clearer and
clearer and has sort of come to dominate
the global political and economic agenda
but at the same time economists are
realizing that the dollar is even more
dominant than they thought
internationally in the global financial
system in trading flows lots of traders
invoiced in dollars even between
countries neither of whom used the
dollar and economists have been
uncovering things like this eventually
you would expect if China continues to
grow anything like the rate it has if
China's rise continues and if the sort
of ratio of China's economy it ever
comes to match sorry the ratio of
China's economy to America's economy
ever comes to match the ratio of their
populations which is something like four
to one you would expect the dollar no
longer to be the global currency there
is a big question mark there about
whether that transition can happen it's
all smoothly or when it might happen
certainly America wouldn't like it
happened so that's one of the bet the
biggest sort of questions for this
century I would say is is is if and when
that might happen
great thank you and on to the next
question margarita hurt I wanted to know
who was actually paying the current
tariffs and asked for examples on both
sides and Sameach do you want to take
that question yeah so there have been a
few attempts to look at this and it's
not that kind of obvious from the outset
who would pay the taxes now legally
importers have to pay tax right that's
when the tariffs are charged but you
might wonder it could be the case that
prices would adjust right so perhaps if
the Chinese exporters with were lowering
their prices to make it into the US
market then actually they could
effectively be paying the cost of the
tariff the attempts out there to look at
what's been happening have tended to
find that most of the cause
of the u.s. tires are being borne by the
US importers now that's not the same
thing as US consumers because obviously
you know companies pay for the imports
and then they decide how to set their
prices for consumers the evidence that
actually those costs have been passed on
to US consumers is much fuzzier there
are some cases for example in tariffs on
washing machines now that that wasn't
part of the us-china dispute that was a
separate tariff dispute but in that's a
kind of widely cited example where it
looks like the tariffs were paid by US
consumers there's other recent evidence
by some economists including the chief
economist at the IMF that suggests that
actually the big retailers may have been
sort of swallowing the costs of some of
the tariffs and shielding consumers to
an extent so that's all to say that so
far it looks like Americans are playing
a paying the price of the tariff but
it's less certain about consumers that
said obviously with each new round of
tariffs it gets harder and harder to
escape the tariffs right so so the next
round of tariffs is is planned to be on
things like the laptops or you know
smartphones
though potentially you know there's a
consumer goods it could be much harder
for the companies it's one of those
costs politically they may not want to
they may want to make consumers aware
that these tariffs are hurting them and
so you know that the answer to that
question in terms of who within America
is paying the cost of those parts that
could change thank you um and we've got
another live question from James panini
how would how is the EU being affected
by all this that's a man what do you
think yeah I think so that you use
position is is is complicated on the one
hand they actually share some of the
concerns that the US has with China on
the other hand they completely disagree
with the tactics that the Trump
administration is using
now the American the Trump
administration would say like okay
Europeans you're quite happy to moan
about the Chinese but are you happy to
do anything so there's a kind of
frustration from the American side that
the EU is all talk and no walk and the
EU has generally been playing a much
friendlier diplomatic game with China in
terms of trying to engage trying to get
it to change his ways that way now that
you've kind of been rebuffed a bit
recently by China so there's a question
of how well that's working so we're sort
of disapproving bystander is how I would
say that the issue is participating in
this the other thing I should say is
that obviously there are many people
watching from the EU what could happen
as part of this us-china deal right
suppose the Chinese essentially promised
to buy a lot of American stuff as part
of this deal that could mean buying less
European stuff right if we go towards a
world of managed trade where the u.s. is
essentially managing trade as it wants
to could that damage European interests
and affect their exporters and importers
so that's the other thing that they're
watching out for I would just add to
that that one thing that's striking
being in London think about the story
when you know people come through the
offices the economy still going around
talking people in Europe to get a
European view on the trade war is just
how uncertain they see it you know
you'll ask them you know what's their
sort of inside of you in Europe of
what's going on in this story and
they'll say oh I better check put out my
phone and check Twitter like everyone
else to see what the president's
tweeting and so certainly I think
there's a that the the extent to which
policymakers in Europe sort of span back
and and and have to deal with immense
uncertainty from economic conflict
between these other powers is quite
striking I don't know if you'd agree
with that Sandman yeah I would I mean
it's really striking essentially what's
happened is that the U has kind of been
semi-frozen out of the talks you know
they would they would as I said they
have these shared concerns there are in
theory these trailer
child talks going on between the EU the
US and Japan to try and work out some
kind of rules that could ultimately be
used to constrain China and deal with
some of the problems that they will
share but the u.s. really hasn't been
treating it as a priority the bilateral
negotiation is really front and center
the US has been clear but the e is not
part of that meanwhile you have one of
this aggressive trade sort of stuff
happening from the Trump administration
to the edu right the Trump
administration has been picking fights
with the EU we're not in a world anymore
where they're negotiating constructively
towards a big trade deal that
transatlantic trade and investment
partnership TTIP that was going on under
the last administration that that deal
is in the deep freeze instead we've got
a much more aggressive bullying
let's pick people off individually
approach and I think a lot of people
regard that as a lost opportunity it's
really interesting thank you and Henry
was a question for you from the
community tab it's going back to the
topic of tariffs specifically if a puts
a tariff on B and B does not retaliate
does that mean a wins if I export to you
without importing anything from you does
it make me a winner so I'm going to take
that in the export import context the
tariff one is is I just have to go and
share the textbook before I answer that
corium like I was it's America that I'll
do export imports first okay I'm it so
throughout the trade war president Trump
has sort of acted as if what was just
said was correct as if it were the case
that if you sold loads of goods to her
to another country and never bought
anything back that would be a sort of
trade victory and therefore if you're in
deficit you're you're you're buying more
than you're selling you're losing out
that is sort of emphatically not the way
economists would look at it for a number
of reasons one is that if you think of
it just in terms of the goods that are
crossing borders were the u.s. two
be shipping goods to China and not
receiving anything in return are you
running a trade surplus and not getting
anything back you know that would that
would be a losing deal they'd be
shipping all these goods overseas and
nothing would ever be coming back think
about in a simple sentence what would B
be happening there well they'd be the
accumulating Chinese currency or Chinese
financial assets in exchange for the
goods now those that Chinese currency
all of those Chinese financial assets
earn your value if you then go round to
China go back to China and actually buy
some goods but from China and in
response or at least go into global
markets and buy to buy goods back this
goes back to a point that the economist
Milton Friedman made I think when the US
was fighting a trade war with Japan
which was you know if if Japan ships us
loads of goods in the United States and
all we ever ship back to them are sort
of dollars pieces of paper Treasury
bills that's pretty good we've got all
this stuff and we just send them pieces
of paper it's only once they try and
spend those pieces of paper on American
goods that something has to be sent back
now the amazing thing about trade as a
political issue is that politicians act
as if it's in their interests to boost
exports and minimize importers and
that's imports and that's basically
because well they might have a sort of
long-run economic vision that involves
doing that but it's basically because
they have lots of exporters banging down
their door saying we need access to
these foreign markets we need to win the
global race you know we we want to
summon to these markets and it's
basically ultimately basically an
influence of those sort of domestic
interests on the politicians the firm's
the workers for those firms that
politicians have that sort of mccandless
maximize X exports attitude and the
amazing thing about the about the global
trading system is it manages to sort of
convert those instincts or has until now
until the trade war is converted those
instincts into energies to get
terrorists down across the board so that
everyone can benefit from trade so it's
I would really encourage people not not
to view trade as that sort of zero-sum
game where you're just trying to you're
just trying to ship your goods to
someone else because altima t you want
back I'll let some air take the terrace
one samman yeah I'm a bit worried though
because Huber's might might get textbook
fatigue I'll have a go just stop me if
it's if it's too much um so I said
before about how it wasn't actually
obvious who would pay the cost of the
tariff right so basically if you are a
big country you can apply a small tariff
and basically the foreign exporters are
all going to lower their prices in order
to maintain the access to your market
right so what you've done there is you
basically squeezed surplus out of those
foreign exporters and so in a sense so
that you know your your the the prices
of the stuff that you're importing
that's getting cheaper that's that's
great your they call your terms of trade
they improve and so in in a kind of
partial sense you are a kind of winner
now the problem is that other countries
do tend to retaliate right and so then
you you have this kind of mutually
destructive situation where you're both
applying tags to each other you're both
worse off and so the point of a trade
deal is to get you to coordinate to move
to a better situation when neither of
you are applying tariffs right because
yes okay it might be best for you to to
apply a small type if you were the only
one doing it but but ultimately they're
going to Italian so everyone's going to
be worse off so trade deals are about
getting a kind of mutually reinforcing
arrangement whereby everyone agrees no
tariffs and we can avoid that
tit-for-tat situation where everyone's
taxing everyone else great really clear
thanks both um so moving on to how the
trade was impacting other countries the
blows in this trade war are being dealt
by China and us but the impact is of
course being felt further afield we've
talked a bit about the EU already but
looking further afield a live question
that's just come in is does this trade
war have an effect on globalization I
don't know who wants to take that Henry
Smith sure so I mean I can speak a bit
first I expect some out we want to
expand it's absolutely been the case
that global supply chains have shifted
and response to the trade war so it has
actually benefited countries like
Vietnam like Malaysia that people we
want to sell into America but avoid the
tariffs would move production out of
China and into those countries and you
can see that already in the data so the
longer the trade war goes on the more of
that supply chain shifting you're likely
to see it's also the case that people
might think twice about making very
long-term investments just on account of
the uncertainty they don't know what the
trade Packers are going to be okay well
anything to add on that so um so first
of all globalization is a very very big
term and I find it helpful to kind of
break it down into a few components so
so first of all so companies essentially
that have they have two decisions right
so how do they locate their production
in order to serve the US market and then
how do they locate their production to
serve the Chinese market right the
reality is that the Chinese market is
growing its massive that's where a lot
of the opportunities are right and so
those shifts in demand those structural
shifts in demand and having a
first-order effect on what companies are
doing right so then the question is okay
well how does this trade war affect the
way that they choose to serve those
markets and basically before they might
have had one big big production hog
where they could sell the same product
so all markets and and that would be
fine but now it's looking like they're
having to they're having to think about
whether actually they're going to have
to have you know perhaps one hub in
China to serve the Chinese market or
perhaps a local Asian neighbors and they
have to move their us rest of world
facing hub outside so that's that's the
kind of a question there and then
there's obviously the question of okay
well if they're going to move them
outside of China do any come back to
North America just production go to
Mexico there's a bigger trend of much
more regionalization within supply
chains so companies are using blocks
like you know within the European Union
or within North America within East Asia
those blocks are probably going to
become more important as you know the
global trading system becomes less
certain as companies respond to the fact
that they can no longer count on secure
access to various markets thanks man
and with that idea of regionalization of
supply chains we've got a question that
relates to that from milan prasad and he
asks will this trade practice benefit
other economies you've touched on it
slightly so far but it's a matter what
you think I think they have an I think
some economies outside of trying to have
an opportunity you know we we tend to
sometimes talk about trade or business
as if it's very very fluid and just kind
of moves around and I think I think the
reality is that actually a lot of these
decisions these relationships are very
sticky they're actually quite hard to
move once the whole cluster is in China
it's very difficult to move the whole
clusters somewhere else there's a huge
coordination problem one of the reasons
China was so successful is it managed to
kind of put you know the zipper maker
the button maker the pocket maker all in
the same place and you have these
amazing production pubs and so those
things are very hard to shift and so now
as a result of all this trade war stuff
other countries now have an opportunity
to try and grab slices that the
previously that were just going to stay
in China probably no matter what and you
know the extent to which they can will
defend will depend on a few things
essentially there was a rule you know I
people went to China because it was big
and it had really good infrastructure
institutions in other places may not be
quite the same the infrastructure might
not be as good the capacity might not be
as good that's one challenge for
countries trying to
sort of you know jump in there China has
ports it has a very very large labor
force who is kind of used to working in
particular conditions that you might not
like the way those conditions are but if
you're a business that there aren't
they're facing some challenges when
trying to seek alternative suppliers and
so you know really one of my big bug
fairs is that sometimes people talk
about trade as this force for good and
change in a way that's kind of abstract
from the institutions that enable that
trade right and so these countries have
an opportunity from the trade war but if
they haven't got the right
infrastructure if it haven't got the
right you know got an educated workforce
if they're going to set up all sorts of
sort of H you know all sorts of PR
scandals by having terrible working
conditions companies don't want that
either and so so there's a there's
there's an opportunity I'm not sure
whether all countries are going to take
advantage of that opportunity as as they
could pass thanks a man and we made a
film last year looking at how to prepare
for a global recession which you can
watch on our Channel
some are saying that there may be a
global recession as soon as next year
Henry you've written a piece looking at
this for the world in 2020 are the
twists and turns of the trade war
hurting global growth so I think I think
they are what's really strange about the
trade although or unexpected is that it
hasn't interacted with the global
economy in quite the way you might
expect so the global economy for some
time has been in this situation where
bond yields are very low interest rates
are very low sort of as far as the eye
can see people don't expect very much
inflation and you might expect that if
you have a trade war in which countries
slapping tariffs on each other and
prices going up all over the place you
might have some sort of an inflationary
spiral in actual fact what's happened
this year and what could continue to
happen is that as the trade was sacked
confidence businesses have reduced their
investment or their desire to invest as
its created uncertainty they've reduced
their and desire to invest and what that
means is that as sort of contributed to
the more disinflationary the more sort
of pessimistic sentiment in financial
markets and actually what that's done is
sort of created a more a sort of
deceleration in the global economy which
looks more conventional ie one in which
inflation expectations are low interest
rates long interest rates have fallen
and so the real question is can the
world economy get through the the
situation is currently in where
sentiment slow and then you ask the
conventional questions about can central
banks stimulate the economy economies
enough to offset that sagging sentiment
and the issue and you've got all kinds
of issues there about interest rates
would have been close to zero and not
having much room to fall you might think
about governments where the government's
can do stimulus and then you've got
issues there about government's already
been quite indebted so the convention
even even seemed off a conventional
recession at the moment is quite a
difficult thing for the world economy to
do which means you've got to look back
to the trip to the sentiment on trade
and think is the sentiment on trade
going to going to pick up and white that
rejuvenate everyone's animal spirits and
and certainly stock markets are doing
okay at the moment I mean we've had
record hot record highs in it in the US
recently but as I was saying earlier
ultimately this story comes down a lot
to the whims of one man and he's
demonstrated his ability to affect
global sentiment greatly and so it's
inherently uncertain but it's certainly
the case that the world economy is in a
slightly precarious juncture at the
moment because of that combination of
sort of low rates that we've been stuck
in for a while and the sort of unknown
of a trade shock that's causing these
this extra sort of reluctance to invest
on the part of businesses right thank
you Henry and we're running low on time
so as a
question if both China and America
boreback tariffs will that be the end of
this or is that just one part of this
increasingly sprawling confrontation I
don't know it's not going to be the end
as a refrain at one point a lot which is
that this is much more than a trade war
I think you know over the last few weeks
in the u.s. it's been the news coming
out about what the Chinese authorities
are doing into Jang on human rights
what's happening in Hong Kong there's a
real there's a sense that the the
actions that they're taking in terms of
human rights are a kind of hardening
opinion you know tariffs are kind of
easy to deal with that that is much much
less easy then you have all of the
national security concerns you have the
changes towards greater export controls
much more control and oversight over
what technology American companies can
share overseas you just have a lot of
action besides the direct tariffs that
speak to a much much colder relationship
between the US and China and much more
uncertainty about what the economic
relationship will will therefore look
like and also in that in a in the very
long term what's the picture here the
picture here is that America is trying
to get China to change the fundamentals
of its economic model China doesn't have
free market start American capitalism it
has state-led capitalism in which is
subsidizes favors interests industries
and in which the space intricately
involved in the economy to the extent
that America is trying to get China to
change that and to the extent that
America sticks to its it's sort of
demands there this could be a very long
running conflict or economic conflict
indeed because China's only doesn't want
to change
economic model and that's the really
long-term reason to think that this is
going to be a an ongoing area of dispute
so now and soon and I said that was the
final question but we're still having
lots of live questions coming through so
and we'll take one more you can answer
quickly which is what could we as
individuals do to improve the impact of
this trade war on our future lives it's
a tricky one that's a tricky one Isis I
mean ultimately the trade war is
something that's governed by the
political process so I think you'd you'd
have to say that whatever your views on
it you'd have to exert your power at the
ballot box and your power love in your
politicians to the extent that's
possible I'm not sure really the trade
war is something that individuals acting
directly can affect that much I'd be
interested what you think's now yeah
yeah I'd say so
I suspect there aren't that many you
know Washington DC trade lobbyists what
you missed for whom the answer might be
a bit different but yeah I think this is
this is one of the biggest ones perhaps
the biggest fight in the role in the
world right now unless you can kind of
go on Fox News and change the
president's mind about various things I
I suspect his advisers are going to have
much more impact I mean I guess the
question was about how to was about the
impact of the trade war though not on
their on the path and so you know what
um you know so there's one kind of
interesting data point which is that the
number of job openings for trade
specialists has been rising very very
quickly right having to hire a lot new
people to think about how to manage all
of this trade supply chain uncertainty
with policy uncertainty so if you want
to go and help a company not try to work
out how to how to adjust and then you
could
I search on it on the job search website
and try and do that
is this your picture of a rush boy
known that note will have to wrap up I'm
afraid and Thank You Henry thank you
some air you've both been great thank
you for watching thank for your
questions don't forget to Like and
subscribe and we'll see you next time
you